hello everybody and welcome to another
python 3 tutorial video in this video
we're going to be talking about is
another one of our standard library
modules and that's going to be url lib
the idea of url lib is it allows you to
buy a python access the internet so just
like the internet it allows you to do
all sorts of amazing things
url lib is going to let you do all sorts
of the same amazing things only using
python in your programming language
so with that let's go ahead and get
started
so there's only a few
i guess a few core things that you need
to do in order to connect and get data
from the internet
but then there's a
slightly more advanced topics that we do
need to cover with url lib but we'll get
there
it's luckily a still fairly simple
module so
with that let's go ahead and get started
the first thing that you're going to
have to do is you're going to need to
import url lib now if you're coming from
python27 you're used to just needing to
do import url lib or import url lab2 and
that's it whereas with python 3
and onward you actually have to do
you're going to be more so doing at
least import url
lib.request
and when you do like url open for
example you'll have to do url dot
request dot url open and so on but
anyway more on that in a little bit
so an example of visiting a website will
be as follows so let's say we'll define
a variable as x we'll say x equals url
live.request.url
open
and then in these parameters is where we
specify the
address that we want to visit you always
have to
leave this with http or https so for
example https colon slash
slash
and let's go to www.google.com
okay and then so that what it's going to
do is going to make a request to that
url okay and this is by default it will
be a get request so it's going to get
some data and that's it
now what we can do is we could say or
let's do print x dot read so we're
reading the request
uh so we can now save and run this
and this is our output just a whole
bunch of
you know gobbly [ __ ]
text but this is basically the source
code of google.com so for example
uh we could open up a browser
and we could go
you know to the top go google.com
hit you
and or control you rather and this is
the source code right so
again it is just a bunch of junk here
but
uh you get the idea that this is what
we've done is we've used
python to reach this page okay
so we can minimize that uh let's go
ahead and close out of that too
and naturally as time goes on and we're
going to cover that very soon but when
you visit a url you're going to need to
parse that page a little bit so you're
not as interested in the html as you are
in this like paragraph text for example
you're probably going to only care about
paragraph text so we're gonna have to
show how to how to handle that and
actually how to handle that we'll be
using another standard library so have
no fear we'll be covering that very
shortly
so the next thing i want to talk about
is post so for example if we were to go
to let's say uh we go back to where we
were
and
we do
the following let's say we want to go to
pythonprogramming.net
and that's where we can get all of our
um sample code if you're not familiar
but if we scroll down to the bottom
there's actually a search bar here we
could search and let's say we search for
basic
okay and you get a bunch of search
results for the keyword basic but if you
look at our url you see that we have
some extra stuff added to the end of our
pythonprogramming.net
so what do we have well
we've got a question mark then we've got
a character s then we've got the equal
sign basic and then and we and then an
and sign and then submit
an equal sign in search so with a little
bit of deduction and reasoning we could
assume that submit is a variable and s
is a variable and they've been defined
as s equals basic and submit eagle
search
and that is true so if you look at
variables
um or at least the links that have
variables in it the first variable will
have a question mark and then the
variable name equals and then all
subsequent variables are going to have
this little and sign and then the
variable equals and it continues on like
that
so that's um this is an example of a get
request we're getting data based on
these
well actually it's a post right we're
getting data based on these posted uh
variables so let's say we want to make a
post request now first of all you could
just get do a get
to this url right you could just use a
request and put in this url but the
other thing that we can do and the more
you know pythonic thing that we're
supposed to do is go to
pythonprogrammer.net add in these values
and do a post to
pythonprogramming.net so let's go ahead
and show how that's supposed to be done
so here i'm just going to comment this
out because we don't need to be printing
that out every time just wanted to show
an example i'm also going to comment
this out because otherwise it's just
going to be visiting every time and we
don't need to do that
now we're going to import another thing
and that's going to be import url
lib dot
and this is going to help us parse
values to our post request
so um
a little bit different this one's going
to be a little bit longer to get data
but
just bear with me so first we're going
to say url and this is just going to be
what url what's like the base url that
we want to visit
and the base url again always lead in
with http colon slash slash uh we're
dot pythonprogramming.net that's it then
we're going to have a dictionary and
we're going to say this dictionary is
called values and then empty parameters
for now but very quickly we're going to
say s
and that s corresponds to basic and then
comma and then our next value is if you
recall submit
and that submit was
called search
so i don't know if i closed it or not no
we didn't okay so our first thing so
it's basically keyword key and value
like a dictionary our keyword is the
variable and then this is the variables
uh definition basically so that's values
now what we do is we come down and we're
going to say data so this is going to be
data from the website equals
url lib.parse dot url and code and we
want to encode values
so first we're just encoding simply
values and what url encode is going to
do is it's going to encode it as it
should be in the url so for example if
we go back to where we've been working
and we go to like google.com and we did
a search for
um
hey
check that out okay you see that it's
hey plus check plus that plus out you
could also do the query is this hey
check that out
at least usually
it's not fit there it goes okay and you
can see that it has changed now to hey
percent 20 check percent 20 that percent
what's that let's see we're all encoding
percent 20 is uh the encode of space
okay
um and then obviously you would need to
have url encoding for like a question
mark and so on so anyway
back to what we're doing and that's kind
of why you want to do it the official
way rather than hard coding because as
soon as you introduce and signs or
question marks
python is not going to necessarily know
which you meant so that's why you want
to do it the official way that we're
doing right now so first we encode
values okay so we've encoded values as
the data that we want to post in
then what we want to do is we're going
to say now
data equals data dot n code and we want
to encode this as
utf-8 this is just a type of encoding
okay so
basically puts your data in bytes now
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to say rec
for request
equals url lib.request
dot capital regret request
i can't talk
what do we want to request the url and
then data so first the url then any of
the data that we want to pass through
and we've encoded that data and we've
encoded it under utf-8 okay so we're
going to request now from this url
pythonprogram.net we're going to pass
the following variables s equals basic
submit equals search
and then after rec we're going to say
resp for response equals
urllib.request.urlopenre
okay so now we're actually
urlab.request.url open we're actually
visiting the url now like we did right
up here so the syntax is identical and
really we just see that we had to do all
of this first
so anyway we've done that
then we're going to say resp data equals
rest.read
and then let's go ahead and print
rest
data so we're going to visit
pythonprogram.net we're going to pass
through those variables um and then
we're going to read the results and
again the results are going to be like
the source code of the results so it's
going to be a little messy but uh
hopefully we'll be able to read a little
bit here so we'll save and run it
apparently sometimes it takes a second
to like run there we go
so it visits it and then here is the
messy junk that we get
um
pretty big mess i'm hoping we can find
something that's actual tech yeah sorry
here's some text here
um you know uh paragraph python 3 basics
tutorial if something do something this
tutorial is a part of the python 3
tutorial series for beginners
and so on so there is you know there's
some content there we're not quite sure
yet how to pull that content out but
nonetheless we did visit the website we
downloaded all the data so what your
browser does for you and what html does
is html basically tells your browser how
it should display
data but that's really it so your
browser handles the html and makes it
pretty for you and separates tags from
text and and organizes things whereas
with with python python is just going to
look at the source you have no um
organization here right
so now um
what i'd like to have us do is
change
one more thing and so here we're making
a request right so we've done a request
so we've done a get really this was a
get very simple just because it's
that's the default so we didn't have to
change anything
and then we've made a post and we've you
know made that post based on data that
we've decided to set but now we come to
a problem that is uh something that will
you'll
fairly soon come across and that is
whenever you want to visit a website
using python or any programming language
sometimes the website owners don't like
that they don't want you on their
website with a robot or a program or
whatever they only want real users on
their website so they will block you if
they sense that you're not a real user
now likely for us this is actually
somewhat easy to fool
basic systems anyways
there are some more complex ones google
just recently made another update
and has made it slightly more difficult
to cheat their system but still you can
overcome these things usually fairly
easily it's almost like i don't know
some sort of filter right if you're not
good enough you can't use it but if
you're good enough i guess you can you
can use their services still with your
program
that said usually websites that block
your access they do it because they
offer an api and they want you to use
their api google offers an api so try to
use google's api before you cheat google
try to use wikipedia's api before you
start cheating wikipedia and just you
know programming your way around it
because the api is going to make it
easier on wikipedia and it's going to
make it easier on you too because they
don't need to send
all of the html data they don't need to
send serve advertisements right because
your program isn't going to read it
that kind of stuff so you do have to
kind of pay a little bit of attention
there
as far as if they have an api or not
now moving along
um
now we're going to need to
i guess we'll show an example so for now
i'm just going to comment this stuff out
so we're not doing that over and over
and now i'm going to come down here
and first let's go and make a try and
accept here we're going to say try
x equals url live.request.urlopen
and the url we're going to attempt to
open is https colon slash slash
www.google.com
search
and then question mark so we're defining
a variable here
uh we're going to say q
equals test so q stands for query
for google so we're going to attempt to
visit this url so this is a search
request for the string text so this is
as if you had went to google and you
typed in test in the search bar you hit
enter
so we're going to attempt to do that so
now that we've done that we'll come down
here and we'll say
save file equals
open um
actually you know what i don't even want
to do this i am positive this will fail
so now instead what we'll do is we'll
just do um
print
x dot read that should be enough and
then we're going to come down here and
we're going to say accept
exception
as e and then we're going to print
string e so what we're going to do here
again attempt to visit google do a
search query then we're going to read
the results the source code of the
results
and we're going to try to do that
otherwise we're going to throw the
exception as e and then we'll print the
string version of that exception so
let's go ahead and run that and just see
what happens to us
so we run that and we get http error 403
forbidden we're forbidden because google
says hey you're a program and we're
going to go ahead and say no
okay so
if you happen to find yourself in this
situation here's how you get around it
so we try to accept that we fail now
what can we do
so let's make some more space and now
let's switch this up a little bit we're
going to do try
and i guess what we'll do
use some of the same code up here but
we'll retype it
um so we're going to try url equals and
we'll use the exact same url so i'm just
going to say url equals um
this
so copy paste the url
then we're going to go ahead and say
headers equals an empty dictionary and
what headers are headers are basically
what the data you send in you send in a
header every time you visit a website
and it contains information on you
who you are your ip
uh your browser your like operating
system all kinds of stuff it sends in a
bunch of information on you
and so within your headers there is a
data piece of data that is called user
agent so now that we've got headers
defined let's make some more space and
we'll say headers
and then square brackets to define a
piece of data in this dictionary and
we're going to call this piece of data
user dash agent so user agent is the
type of browser basically that you are
using
so in our case what uh python does is it
says python dash url lib slash and then
your python version so for me it would
be 3.4
so
within almost an instant when you visit
a website with python using the methods
that we've shown so far
that website knows exactly where you are
they know you're a program so it's very
easy for them to shut you down because
you send in you basically say hello
knock knock my name is python all right
and and they and then their servers say
hell no and they shut you out so now
what we want to do is we're going to say
user agent and the user agent that we're
going to use is a little long i don't
want to have to type it out so i'm going
to go ahead and just copy and paste it
like this
and i'll just put a link to it in the
description if i happen to forget
someone remind me but hopefully i want
so paste and we get this long
user agent here
you can't even really see it all in my
window but this is it
okay so super long user agent
basically uh this tells um
well this acts like we're using mozilla
and then it gives all this other
information and all this compatibility
stuff
um
and so basically it just said it just
changes that we're no longer are we
uh announcing ourselves as python
sorry about that i have no idea where i
left off i'll just kind of start at this
point here
turns out my dog knows how to open a
sliding glass door so
he was
running around in here when he uh
shouldn't have been that was very
surprising
anyway
um
yeah okay so here we're just we're
replacing our uh user agent
and so in an attempt to fool google so
we'll see if we can so
there's our user agent now we're gonna
do basically the same thing we did
before and we're gonna say rec
equals urllib.request.capitalrequest
and then we're going to make the request
to the url and then we're going to go
ahead and remember before we said data
well we're not going to pass through any
data uh here because
um
we're like hard coding it in right
under normal circumstances you would
maybe say like if we're making a post
request we could do that and then we
would add in the whole search data or
the values and make the posts but
instead we're just going to hard code
this for now
feel free to mix them on your own time
homework assignment
uh url and then we're going to say
headers equals
headers okay so we're telling uh python
now to visit this url and instead of
setting our normal headers the default
parameter headers we're going to change
these up and call the headers this
now
in my opinion it just kind of makes a
little bit of sense to eventually
go into
urllib.request.request that's a function
and in that function it has function
parameters and they define a
default value for headers
why not just go in there edit uh the url
lib function there and make this your
default header just a thought for some
of you guys anyway moving right along
so now we that's we've defined what the
request is now we're going to say
response equals urllib.request.urlopen
and url we want to open basically his
request with the following thing as our
headers
so that's our response now we're going
to say resp data equals rest.read
and now
the amount of data here is actually kind
of big right because there's a whole
search result page
and all the html that goes with it it's
very big and bulky and so if we run this
right now and we were just to print it
out to console
it would lag the console fairly well
so we don't want to do that so instead
what we'll do is we're going to call
we're going to say save file equals open
and we're going to call this file with
headers.txt we're going to open it with
the intention to write then we're going
to say save file.right
and then we're going to write
we have to write the string version of
rest data because right now the response
data isn't uh in string format so that's
also kind of new ish if you're coming
from python 27
and then of course we need to do save
file dot close
now the other thing we have not done is
we did a try and we have no accept yet
so we're going to say accept
exception as
e
and then we're going to go ahead and
print
string e just in case we throw an
exception hopefully we don't if unless
i've screwed up or something we
shouldn't
then we're going to come over here this
is where that file will go is it'll just
go right over here
and we should be ready to run this so
let's go ahead and save and run that
and the first one i'll throw i can't
remember okay so the first one throws
the forbidden
yeah because we're still trying this but
the second one worked because we didn't
see a four bit in we come over here here
it is with headers we can open it with
notepad plus plus
and here's all of our data so obviously
it's a bunch of junk you know but this
is all search results there were some
images there um
eventually we could maybe get to some
some sort of text or something but
anyway
this is a huge mess um google results
are pretty messy um but anyway we were
able to get by google's little filter
for uh for just anybody right
so but if you if anybody had just read
the documents you'd find out how easy it
is to change your headers but a lot of
people don't read documents so i guess
that's that's why
so
that's going to conclude the basics of
url lib now again the data where we're
fed back is just this huge mess of data
like what do we even do with all this
data so then you have to kind of parse
through the data so the next thing that
we're going to need to learn is regular
expressions to actually parse through
this data and our regular expressions
are
kind of scary to people sometimes mostly
because
it's its own programming language
entirely so everything you know about
python up until now doesn't mean
anything for when it comes to regular
expressions
but luckily
regular expressions being their own
programming language basically
are transferable pretty much anywhere
you go the rules of regular expressions
will remain so once you understand the
logic of regular expressions you can
take it to any language it's a lot like
sql right if you learn sql or as the
cool kids say it sequel
it's it's its own programming language
and you can take it anywhere uh to any
other programming language and work with
sql or sql whatever you want to call it
so anyway
getting a little ahead of ourselves but
i do want to say that we're going to be
covering regular expressions very soon
and then after we cover it we'll mesh
regular expressions with url libs so a
lot like your basic programs are just a
combination of very or your complex
programs rather are just a combination
of very basic tools
even some of these really complex tasks
are a lot of times just the combination
of really basic modules and tools that
you already have maybe not if statements
and all that but
you know url lib plus regular
expressions equals a pretty darn good
website parser already you could also
use something like beautiful soup but if
you look into beautiful soup most of
what beautiful soup is is url lip and
regular expressions so
anyway uh that's going to conclude this
video uh if you guys have any questions
or comments about url lib please feel
free to leave them below if you guys
have any requests about
more information on url live or some of
the other built-in site packages or even
third-party modules that you want me to
cover film in the series right now so if
you happen to do it you know fairly
recently to win this video is posted
i'll probably be able to include it in
the series so anyway
uh that's it as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time